- Good afternoon.
With the holiday season fast approaching,
we wanted to take a moment
to address some online threats
that could make the internet
an unsafe place as the
year draws to a close.
- For most of us the holidays
mean spending time with family.
So it's important then
that families know what they should post
on our Facebook.
- [Justin] Nothing.
- [Zack] Nothing.
("Return To You")
- Under no circumstances
should you post anything
to our Facebook, families.
- Uncle Roy, I'm not politically active,
especially not on Facebook,
and especially not for you know who.
- And Mom, I know that's
a cute picture of me,
that's why I posted it.
You don't need to remind all my friends.
- Aunt Carol, I promise I have seen
every single baby hippo video.
Seriously.
So much it would destroy you.
- Kurt, I know you're my cousin and all,
but please stop hitting on my friends.
They're not going to be sure to chill
when you visit.
Y'all have my number.
- And you have my email.
- Maybe send it just to me.
- It's not that I'm embarrassed.
It's like-
- It's just sometimes,
I'd rather-
- Keep it in the family.
- Exactly.
Keep it in the family.
- Which is why we're starting the hashtag,
hashtag keep it in the family.
- So help your family out.
When they something,
and I mean anything on your Facebook,
gently remind them-
- Hashtag keep it in the family.
- And together we can have a safe-
- And private-
- Holiday season.
Thank you.
("Return To You")